nah I with the quoting thing I
definitely don't agree definitely
I don't understand how you're meant to
get to know somebody if it's not through
courting but I said before like what
exactly would one Define quoting as
right so actually I forgot to say this
but yeah so the definition of courting
courting is the time before a
relationship starts when the couple gets
to know one another exchange gifts and
generally keep a respectful distance
with little to no intimacy so the way I
understood it is courting is like no sex
yeah I definitely
yeah I definitely think that women like
there has to be a period of quoting I
don't understand other people they might
not they might feel like oh they don't
want to do quoting or dating but that's
fine go find the people that you don't
want to do it with me I could only be
with somebody who is willing to take
that time without sex as well and get to
know me on a me level and yes go out and
spend money on me as well yes okay what
do you think I'll be honest like caught
in
it doesn't have to be in my opinion like
actually going out going out for drinks
taking out buying me fancy stuff caught
in again I do agree that there's certain
level of like women that should be
courted that again deserve to be quoted
and again it just depends on how you
want to get to know that person but do I
think you need to not have
sexual intercourse yeah at first what do
you think absolutely not
why am I the one doing the courting like
I'll I will say yes when a woman takes
me on a date then I'll be like yeah yeah
but until then you're on my time so now
okay
I I agree with what Kevin Samuel says
because nowadays what's courting you
talk to somebody for maybe one to two
weeks and then you have sex with them or
you meet them have sex with them on the
first day like what what is courting
nowadays when it when does it go from
courting to talking to dating it's just
like nowadays there's really no such
thing as courting like traditional
according yeah do you think it's because
the women now don't typically deserve it
because they're not they're not the
things that men value anymore
um I mean essentially yes if we're going
off of the things that men value in
women it's like
not saying that
I mean yeah essentially if men if men
want this and it would be on the flip
side if women wanted this and they're
expecting a man to have this they would
Court them but it's like men want this
and it's like a lot of women aren't
having or don't have what men want and
so it's like why would you if you're
going to buy a car you would want
everything you wanted souped up
everything everything like great in it
you're not gonna buy it if it's not
exactly what you want yeah okay what do
you think kit
um so we are we can we just establish
you're saying quoting is the is the
non-sexually intimate period before
so he said courted like a traditional
woman so yeah like you in the clip so
what I was thinking is the same way like
they courted in the 1950s I mean I mean
that's not happening now like and so so
it says courting is the time before
relationship starts when the couple gets
to know one another exchange gifts and
generally keep a respectful distance
with little to no intimacy so I'd say
quoting is definitely the case aside
from that last part okay as in terms of
to zero to sexual intimacy before
relationship because nowadays like and
even girls as well nowadays people want
to have sex before they get into a
relationship with someone so they know
that they like it yeah so if if courting
is only all of that plus no sexual
intimacy until the relationships of the
difference between courting it yeah yeah
no that's not uh yeah yeah so recording
is like without sex and then dating is
with sex no that's not I don't think
that happens yeah so you don't you don't
think modern women deserve it what Corey
uh
I mean if
unless she's like unless she's a modern
woman
the average
just say it bro
like No Sex in this time nah it's not
happening yeah okay go ahead well I'm
I'm okay courting a woman but she has to
display traditional traits okay facts
yeah like so if she's a modern woman
I'm going to want to know just given the
given the hookup culture state of
society that we're in I want to know her
history on another sexual history it
might be too much to ask off the bat but
personally given us given the time we
live in I want to know what her sexual
history is because
if if I'm having to court her
essentially no sex but the dating aspect
but I know that she's given it up to men
in the past why the [ __ ] am I why why
the [ __ ] am I spending my time money
energy
on you if you've just handed it out to
people in the past it's like a it's like
a used Honda Civic for a BMW price yeah
yeah so I'm I'm not I'm not gonna put
I'm not gonna put work in and time and
have patience that men in the past
weren't required to just because she was
able to give it up in in a certain state
of emotion I'm not willing to do that so
first things first I don't really feel
like traditional women sorry modern
women deserve the traditional type of
courtship that they did back then but if
you are deserving of it you better be
feminine you better be loyal you you
better have all of these things in place
because if like I said if I'm if I'm
having to treat you the way a
traditional man would yet you're
exhibiting nothing traditional as they
did back then and you have a [ __ ] sexual
history I'm [ __ ] gone okay what do
you think
I'm just I just feel like it's really
not that deep okay do you know what I
mean like
no
not that deep for you but someone's
having to take you out like differently
why does it matter if a woman's
traditional or modern I just don't get
why because that's go ahead no no Karen
no Karen no because that's that's what
men want like I don't know what what
your type is but say you wanted XYZ in a
man you're not gonna go for something
that you don't want and essentially men
want modern traditional traditional
women and that have the quality so
they're going to look for that they're
going to go after that
it's like the the market dictates the
the price
and so if you if you have a girl that's
more traditional more guys want her
typically
um I mean you know how everybody's been
saying modern women don't necessarily
deserve to be courted
um I would say that the only reason that
view may be held is because women have
sex
to
willingly and if women were more careful
with how they had sex the price of the
value of the JJ would go back to how it
it would be what it actually is as
opposed to because right now Vijay has
been devalued because it's everywhere
and that's why you men can say that
women don't deserve to be courted when I
don't I think all women should be
courted
if you're interested in even a hooker
yes
yes why would she deserve to be courted
why not because she gives it to
everybody why on Earth would you wow
right where women are far more than
their like vagina or their sexual status
you just contradicted yourself though no
I said that the value of the JJ has
reduced
women
give so much yeah yeah that doesn't
change the value of people that kind of
implies that the value right but the
world the world doesn't owe you
understanding so I don't the men don't
go to women and say accept me short
except me broke except me fat but we go
to them and say accept us ran through
that's not that's not a fair deal
some women a lot of women do accept men
that are short um as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible